(gentle percussion music)
- It's no secret that,
on a day-to-day basis,
most people claim to lack
the motivation necessary
to make any significant
positive changes in their lives.
It's almost a meme in today's culture
that people are just generally
lazy and unmotivated,
helpless against their own
primal desires to veg out
and scroll Instagram,
cringing at the very thought
of dropping the phone and
cleaning their entire kitchen.
Every once in a while,
though, something triggers us.
Maybe it's a deadline, a
post we saw on Instagram,
or a Tony Robbins video we
just happened to stumble across
on YouTube, and it gives us
the adequate inspiration needed
to perform the actions necessary
for improving our situation.
But here's something
that almost nobody knows.
Action is not just the
effect of motivation,
but also the cause of it.
Most people only commit to action,
when they feel motivated to do so.
And they only feel motivated
when they feel a certain amount
of emotional inspiration.
Emotional inspiration gives
us the adequate motivation
to perform a constructive action.
But there's a huge
problem with this system.
Aside from the issue
that inspiration seems
to strike us randomly and unpredictably,
there's an even bigger problem.
Often, our negative attitudes
towards our bad situations
hinders us from experiencing any sort
of emotional inspiration
towards changing the situation
in the first place.
If you have an attitude
of massive guilt, shame,
resentment or fear towards
your current situation,
then the very thought of
confronting this monster
is likely to inspire the very emotions
that put you in that
situation to begin with.
It's a Catch-22.
So how do you fix this?
Well, by realizing that
emotional inspiration,
adequate motivation,
to constructive action
is not a linear sequence,
it's an endless loop.
And you can start wherever
you want to start.
Inspiration leads to motivation,
which leads to action,
which leads to inspiration,
which leads to motivation, et cetera.
If you lack the inspiration or motivation
to take constructive
action, then do something.
Anything really.
Then harness the reaction from that action
to give you the adequate inspiration
and motivation to take further action.
And you might be thinking,
"Well, how am I supposed to do something
without any inspiration?"
Well, whether you realize it or not,
you do this all the time.
Ever notice you're much more productive
after taking a shower and getting dressed?
Did you have to have some sort of big,
inspirational epiphany in
order to take a shower?
No, it's just something you do.
(shower splashing)
Some actions require little
to no inspiration whatsoever,
(toothbrush cleaning)
and those are the very actions
(spray spritzing)
whose reactions you should harness
into taking further action.
So next time you're avoiding
some huge thing you gotta do,
don't just sit there and
wait for inspiration to hit.
Just go and do something.
Then harness the reaction from that action
to give you the adequate inspiration
and motivation to take further action.
And this is the Do Something Principle.
(barbell clattering gently)
(soft piano music)
Hello.
If you like this video,
then you will love Mark Manson's article
called "The Do Something Principle."
This entire video was
based off of that article.
It was not my own original thoughts.
Those are Mark Manson's thoughts.
I'll put a link in the description,
for that article, down below.
And if you guys don't already know,
Mark Manson's also the article of...
The article. He is an article.
Mark Manson's also the author
of "The Subtle Art Of Not Giving A"
which is an awesome book.
Highly recommend it.
The link in the description is there
for you to click on.
It's also an Amazon Affiliate link,
so if you want to help out the channel
by purchasing that book,
or anything else, through that link,
you also give me a small,
I mean, it's like
probably $2 or something,
but it does help.
If you like this video,
hit that Like button.
If you like videos like these in general,
hit that Subscribe button.
If you're into self-improvement
and productivity,
that's what this channel is all about.
I have videos just like this
coming out on the regular.
So if you don't want to miss
it, hit that Subscribe button
and also hit that bell
icon, which will notify you
when I upload a new video.
Also, this was a bit of a
different style of video,
so if you dig it, let me
know in the comments section.
Was it a good change or did it not,
was it not very good?
That's all for today.
Thank you for watching,
and we'll catch you in the next video.